a rights group Amnesty International has
released a damning report on the quote
deep denial of Britain in the us-led
coalition over civilian casualties
during the ISIL operation in the Syrian
city of Raqqa the UK Ministry of Defence
still maintains its hundreds of
airstrikes in Raqqa resulted in zero
civilian casualties a statistical
improbability it is completely
reprehensible that the Coalition refuses
to acknowledge its role in most of the
civilian casualties it caused since the
coalition campaign against ISIL in Syria
and Iraq began in 2014 the UK has
carried out some 1,700 airstrikes 215 of
them on the city of Raqqa alone earlier
this year
Britain's Defense Ministry admitted
responsibility for just a single
civilian death and some British MPs
agree with Amnesty International that
the UK authorities appear to be in
denial during a strike to engage three -
fighters a civilian motorbike crossed
into the strike area at the last moment
and it was assessed that one civilian
was unintentionally killed the
government's assertion is part of a
wider strategy of denial around the
consequences of Britain's military
campaign in Syria and Iraq
Britain's defense ministry told us that
the UK has provided details on each of
their 1700 strikes including operational
briefings and confirmed when there was a
civilian casualty and added that
missions are carefully planned and aimed
at minimizing the effect on civilians
adding that it would prefer to have been
involved in the research of Amnesty
International we discussed out the whole
scenario with political commentator
Jonathan Shafi as part of a more general
strategy to cover up - in some way
paper over the Kanes of civilian
casualties that are caused by UK action
this is of course something which
stretches beyond the situation in Raqqa
we heard the same about the Iraq war we
heard the same about Afghanistan as well
we hear over and over again that these
strikes are meticulous strategic using
the best technology that money can buy
but in the end it's dropping bombs and
explosives on densely populated civilian
locations the language that's used
around us meticulous
you often hear as well of course
famously or infamously collateral damage
in fact these are real people and if you
read the reports coming out of Raqqa
there's a real anger the way civilians
have been treated not least because
there's not even an undertaking to have
an investigation and to how these areas
were taking place
you